sex beauty modeling campaign you know
but in your head you're thinking [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but it comes across on
your face like really really elegantly
I'm Eugene Lee yang and I'm a video
producer at BuzzFeed motion pictures
many people think that we're just actors
but we're actually also writers
producers directors editors we
essentially do everything from top to
bottom on a shoot I'm responsible for a
lot of the bigger hits that we've had
virally I am just very particular about
how I want my videos to come out the
companies expect you need to create one
big viral video per month that'll really
just knock it out of the park across
platforms that's a lot of pressure to be
under but I strive under that pressure I
have one big concept that I've always
wanted to do wedding dresses
across the world what I envision is this
huge runway show that just showcases
gorgeous expensive gowns that women
either historically or today who would
be able to wear for their wedding day
and just have them strut [ __ ] out hey
Eugene
Andrew Andrew Gautier is the executive
producer of BuzzFeed motion pictures so
I'm excited to see how well he takes the
idea of wedding dresses around the world
so what's given in this money no well
okay I really wanted to do something
with wedding gowns how do you think it's
gonna do though I think this will blow
up all right and you really think you
can do it by deadline I think I can get
it done one week I just need I don't
think well thinking you know I know no I
don't Lea again I need a lot of time I
honestly don't know about that
this is we're talking about around the
world this needs like a lot of prep time
all right all right this is on you don't
worry about it I got this okay
oh well enjoy your trip in London okay
yeah let's connect when I get back all
right and just make it work I will now
[ __ ] do it I always do it
hey hey don't fall out the window right
I think people might associate me even
with in BuzzFeed as someone who has
ridiculously high standards but for me I
just think sometimes quality comes at a
cost and that cost can be people's
comfort we demand so much of the people
around him maybe to the point where he
doesn't think a lot about the people
around him I don't think that he puts a
crazy amount of pressure on people I
think that people see how much pressure
he puts on itself and then they're just
like oh god I have to make this perfect
what people don't know about BuzzFeed
Cruz is that we don't have crews we
actually use our own interns for the
time being I have luckily been assigned
to different interns the first intern I
have is Caroline who will be primarily
focused more on the production side I've
just heard that it's gonna be intense
you know a lot of that's right
she it's like really intense Jasmine my
second intern will be focused more on
the style aspect but she is pretty green
to production and film sets if I need to
be coached through it that I do but if
not I'll just act like I know what I'm
doing and make sure it looks good I'm
super worried because I haven't worked
with these interns before and this is
the really the first time where you know
all eyes are really on me as a producer
in a director and as an editor to make
something fantastic because if it is
fantastic you get to see how great I was
but if it sucks then you have to see how
much [ __ ] I'm spewing right now so
it better be good Carrie as my research
liaison I just need to know how many
wedding dresses we can get from how many
different countries and hopefully we can
pull together like I don't know 10 to 20
10 to 20 like 10 to 20 to society you're
gonna need to narrow it down man let's
say world right now but if you have to
whittle down I would say uncomfortable
with looking at Asia this may have to
just
the Asian okay cool so if you can start
researching access to fashion designers
who are from that country and really
represent that style authentically we're
definitely need to find out who we're
going with internationally because we're
gonna have to get it through customs to
it we don't get special customs can
you'd be like it's for a bus you know
they will laugh at you okay well
Caroline Jasmine who are you
Liana Liana are you is she my other
intern oh I just found out today that I
was gonna be on this shoot you guys
we're gonna be fine we're gonna be great
so I'm just getting caught up in all
this
I've actually secured five different
designers from each country and then one
extra designer who's doing the
traditional western style gown actually
the Afghan designer is the cousin to the
Crown Prince if again Afghanistan so
really legit yeah she basically just
designs for diplomats and and royalty oh
yeah I've been talking to a designer in
Thailand she's gonna be sending dresses
from New York in hello yeah she's in
Thailand this will be around the budget
okay what are the countries that are
represented the countries that are
represented I've whittled it down to
Korea Vietnam Afghanistan Thailand in
India
while we have to do is put the
plexiglass down we're just gonna serve
as a runway we're gonna finish the
lighting I'm aiming at getting our first
shot off at 10:00 a.m. I have my Fitbit
on with my heart rate monitor I'm gonna
keep track of that and keep it mellow
watch the gowns with the coffee all
right now watch the tit watch the bottom
watch the bottom of the gowns Oh Lord
yeah okay just be careful try to get off
the first shot at 11:00 now it's my goal
so I want to get it centered because
this is gonna be how is lying so and
there's a black spot right there clean
with that black spot what is that is
that lint like a quarter inch back now
there's a little too now like eight the
Minch just a little bit to your right
shade just a tiny bit no you're just
rotating it Caroline lift with him and
pull it slightly to your right chin very
slightly what stop the first shot will
be when the first shot decides to happen
just got to make sure it's all perfect
hope
that was a ninja move yeah thank you for
making this Jasmine find all the
delicate gold pieces we might be able to
use it on this post county no this is
the tie jewelry there should be a
Ralph's paper bag that has all of the
Georgia I would sprint and make sure
it's there
oh here we go oh my god my brain this is
like $10,000 worth of jewelry we check
this is uber strips off is that Alright
and wait how do I get out
Caroline I'm you good yes
let's uh roll cameras music you're
actually on the wedding aisle okay
you're walking down to your husband
right here
and action hi my name is Michelle e bear
and I'm one of the designers on set
today the hits it's turn left boom boom
boom yeah so just really breathe like
boom boom but you always want to be kind
of like 31 ish degrees okay so it's not
here and it's not like here it's like
right there I think this should be like
lower slightly I don't want to make your
designer mad
hi I'm Katherine Waldron I'm the
Novartis he's very professional but he's
freaking crazy gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous yes yes
oh all your jewelry feels so good but
you can have it cuz it's mine because
I'm the queen of Thailand whatever loser
flip out good yes great cut
you guys you're on that cover right yes
all right let's uh switch lenses I'm the
designer for the Afghan clothes so one
of the models was too thin for the
dresses so they called me in and turn
the camera and post oh wow I'm Sofia I'm
not a model I don't know Matt oh wow
you're amazing I'm the designer for the
Vietnamese right circle right perfect
perfect perfect and set model we are
over halfway through now you are all
doing amazing job my mom designs for the
Korean traditional dress yeah you are
working that dress beautiful well Korea
turn I'm here to provide henna designs
you know who the queen is oh yes it's
you so you're gonna exit get out of
there
whatever [ __ ] is one more time I want
you to really sell this less there walk
away and stare at them stairs them stare
at them stare at them stare at them turn
and good that's a wrap
let's get you out those gorgeous clothes
and into like a pizza box I'm hungry I
want to learn more about big sets and
how we can use this space to create
sorry it's late I'm taking away like
opening up people's minds and I'm really
passionate about that as well I know I
can be a bit of an ass sometimes but you
know that's just Asian parents hanger
rule number one you know you gotta be
strict you got to get everything down
because in the end they're gonna succeed
and they succeeded today they were great
so I've been editing about three days
now I see about a million mistakes that
were made Sofia was wearing leggings
under the dress so I have to cut around
[ __ ] leggings but it's cool but you
know things like that you don't notice
it on a shoot and you sit here and then
you're like [ __ ] everything is wrong
that's kind of how I think most of Micra
see footage is everything looks bad but
you know otherwise I think it looks it
looks pretty it looks pretty damn good
for for what we were given I think
everyone involved on this shoot from the
fashion designers to the models to all
the interns and the crew did an amazing
job and I'm so proud of what we
accomplished with such little means it's
always like comparing it to having a
baby
not nearly as paint well I don't know
what it's like to have a baby but it was
pretty painful I feel like it just
pushed out a human out of my phantom
vagina so yeah it's about to be leased
upon the world wedding dresses across
Asia and I really hope you guys enjoy it